clora everyone how's everybody doing I
hopefully everybody had a good New Year
Happy New Year okay
I certainly did I did fine well I'm
gonna just say that this channel is
about rational science what we do here
is science
it's called rational because we do
something different than what the
establishment does so if you came to get
new ideas or a different perspective you
came to the right place you might think
at first sight at first hearing that
well everybody says that no this is
different
and if you stick around you'll realize
that that's the case what we do here
primarily is physics okay
but sometimes we branch off and digress
and go on a tangent and do some other
subjects like we've been doing like
these philosophy we've been dealing with
ain't Rand and he and also we've been
doing extinction the extinction of man
quite a lot a popular subject really and
extinction of past animals right animals
that died long time ago and yeah I'd
like to start this year in fact I
started the other day but really I was
finishing off 2019 and I really start
the year today and today I'm going to do
geometry but before I do I want to kind
of tie some loose ends on extinction
I've been doing extinction for now at
least 20 years and I can't seem to get
the message through and I'm not talking
about people believing in the theory I'm
talking about people understanding it
right now I fear that there's a lot of
people out there that don't understand
it partly because they have different
set of assumptions
okay and yeah if you have a different
set of assumptions and you're not
listening to my assumptions then there's
going to be a contrast okay we were
gonna have differences okay
so yeah they've heard it all in 20 years
but there are many things that are
repeatable that you hear over and over
again
certain questions and things that pop up
over and over again and so what I've
done is I made a little bedtime story to
kind of synthesize what some people say
out there well a lots of people really
say out there or the answers they give
me or the questions they have and it
gives you an idea at least from my point
of view that these people did not
understand squat of the theory okay just
just because of the answers they give me
and the questions that they ask I can
tell the guy wasn't listening or he is
thought this was business and usual said
oh yeah I've heard that before
no you haven't heard what what's what I
proposed here you won't find it anywhere
on the Internet
so if you think that you heard it before
then you for sure you're not paying
attention you're not listening so what I
did was I did a little bedtime story
that you can tell your kids okay
and it kind of puts it all together the
type of questions irrational answers
that some of these people give also you
know to the issue of extinction kind of
put it a little story so that we can get
it rolling here okay so let's see if we
can do that if the action takes place 65
million years ago and in the tradition
of Plato
maybe Socrates for sure Galileo it's
gonna be a dialogue okay dialogue
between tooth Triceratops as' okay
Triceratops was a a herbivorous dinosaur
probably the last big one that was on
earth of the dinosaurs and they probably
made the last man in Hell Creek Montana
that's probably the last place where
there were at least big dinosaurs right
and so this story takes place then it's
a dialogue between them and let's see if
you can more or less place it through
what these people say today about about
how to survive extinction why the
extinction is not going to happen and
that kind of sort of thing what's
happening really here is that you know
like I said it a couple vids act but
what happens is you know these people
don't know anything or haven't done any
research on extinction and the
extinction of the animals that have
become extinct but they're all experts
they're all experts on why man won't
become extinct and that's that's the
problem
you know and these people think that
we're not going to suffer the same fate
as the animals in the past because we
humans are not animals and you say what
do you mean we're not animals and they
say well we're animals what we're not
that's the answer I get a yes and a no
and so either our animals or we're not
we use the word animal consistently or
we don't that's the problem and right
now they're saying well we're not added
we're animals but we're not animals what
do they mean by that well the animals
died because they were dumb and we're
smart and so we won't die like they did
because we have technology we have
intelligence we have foresight and we
we're not gonna suffer the same fate and
so the question is you know are we
different animals I mean what kills an
animal what why does an animal die
animal dies because of the same things a
human dies you know it dies of disease
an accident
maybe genetic stuff or old age lack of
food you know these are the reasons an
animal dies an individual animal dies
and we die for the same reasons I mean
you cannot have a different reason for
humans than for any individual human
than you have for any individual animal
we
for similar reasons as any any other
animal or any other mammal especially in
the Wild Kingdom and so they say well
yeah okay but when it comes to the
species disappearing we're not like them
that's where they establish that this
distinction why be killed well some
people say we have trade they don't have
trade we have intelligent they don't
have intelligence and so on and so forth
that's when we become non animals it's
like the biological factors don't matter
anymore okay anyways here's the
discussion between two Triceratops Asst
okay and the name of one of them is the
Longhorn and the other one is Joe tiny
tusk okay and let's see if we can this
tuned in to their discussion see if we
can listen to what they're talking about
hey one says how did our ancient
brothers them Vivienne's disappear how
did the arcus ores die well our
Triceratops hurt leader big bull told us
that it was an asteroid and he's in now
30 on the matter so I take his word as
law there is also another theory that
says that there were there was a volcano
eruption in those days others rumor that
gamma rays from a nearby supernova
perhaps zapped the earth and took the
fullest breath away they ended up
gasping for air okay and of course
there's also the ever-present climate
change that's so hot these days don't
you agree even the ginkgo coconuts are
melting and is anoxia and methane
sprouting from the deep oceans and dust
clouds that eclipse photosynthesis who
knows who cares I mean what do you think
we are animals we are not amphibians or
insects or birds or fish we are
Triceratops us we are bigger and
mightier than anyone before us that
ever will or that ever will be we can
withstand anything Mother Nature throws
in our path but Joe our world is
obviously coming to an end
as you can see by the Cretaceous
terrestrial revolution graph plant
species and numbers are disappearing
angiosperms are taking over the land the
flowering plants are reducing our
sources of food I'll survive
I'll plant Saikat seeds and my personal
meadow all the other Triceratops will
eat their hearts out dull just watch and
starve to death from the other side of
the fence just in case I can also
produce conifers artificially in my
personal jungle garage a pine tree bark
and [ __ ] Christmas stones did you know
you can eat those artificial cones and
how tasty they are
anyways worst case I'll survive by
trading magnolia leaves and grasses for
ginkgo stems if we could just get those
Illuminati t-rex's of our backs
tiny tusks we lost our genetic diversity
these tiny mammals that scurry about at
our feet have more genetic diversity
than our entire herd of Triceratops uns
our population pyramid is definitely an
irrevocably overturning we are becoming
older and having fewer kids you're
panicking unnecessarily bill that
doesn't lead to extinction if most of
the Triceratops has died out there me
and the missus here we will produce new
generations of Triceratops Eze and
populate the world again
that's the type of dialogue I've been
engaging in for twenty years now those
are the type of replies I get and
apparently these people have it in their
minds that they're gonna survive
Triceratops is new better than they had
more intelligence than some of these
people anyways I thought I'd tie some
loose ends there make it plain that the
answers I've received are not even worth
considering and again the great problem
is that people do not do research on
past extinctions they do not address the
issue of whether food has anything to do
with extinction and when you even though
that is said and done then they say well
we're not animals anyway so we're not
gonna die like them and what else what
else can you talk you know I mean that's
it that's the submarine okay anyway
today I begin a little bit of geometry
and I picked on geometry to start the
year because that's the foundation of
mathematical physics okay
yes a foundational mathematical physics
you have both math and physics and they
kind of merge here I have a little Venn
diagram puts it in perspective geometry
is is an attempt to merge math with
physics that's what it is
you take the physical objects from
geometry and you take the angles and the
numbers from mathematics and you put
them together and you end up with this
thing they call geometry okay what I'm
gonna hurt you is that geometry is an
irrational religion geometry is an
attempt to merge the unmerciful that was
just very concealable you cannot you
cannot merge physics with math math with
physics math is math physics is physics
and never the twain shall meet
okay that's the way I've always put it
physics abuse with physical objects math
deals with quantities measurements and
calculations equations you know so what
does one thing you have to do with the
other math describes physics explains
again nothing whatsoever math to do with
physics yeah that's going to be my
argument so you know in advance already
and if that's not new to you okay well
then good for you you know you heard
this somewhere else
yeah math has nothing to do with physics
physics with math in fact math has
nothing to do with science whatsoever
that's gonna be the argument here we do
not use math in science and the reason
we do not use math and science science
is about explaining math is about
describing that's why math has nothing
at all to do with science or physics
physics on the other hand is a branch of
science and in science we explain
rationally and in physics we explain
mechanisms and causes rationally okay
and I'm not going to get into the word
rational because I've done that in the
past but I will again for those who
missed it in the future okay anyways the
foundation of geometry is the point and
you probably heard of the point
somewhere in high school you know I mean
everybody takes at least one course I
guess in math or geometry you they've
heard of the word point somewhere lying
right so I think everybody to some
degree is familiarized with the word
point the question we're gonna analyze
is what is it being you know what is it
then for what does this word stand for
and it's the foundation of geometry and
geometry is the foundation of
disciplines such as quantum mechanics
and general relativity I put a little
chart here and puts it in the right
perspective again so geometry is the
foundation of math Fez okay the point is
the building block of geometry
okay so geometry is foundations of
mathematical physics
I don't caught physic just fart math
math Mitch mathemagics I caught because
they explained everything with magic and
the point is the building block of
geometry so you can see how important
the point is to mathematical physics
quantum mechanics and general relativity
invoke the point okay quantum mechanics
particles are point masses or charges or
particles or corpuscle or whatever they
want to call it okay so that's what uh
how the point enters quantum mechanics
the were little small it enters the
world are the big as well because in gr
an event which is also the bread and
butter the building block of general
relativity event for four coordinates
established an event the location or
whatever they mean by that because
that's not clear either and a the event
is a point in space-time that's how it's
defined so the point is important for
both general to be quantum mechanics and
even strength theory and books the point
when it builds its lines on there they
go into brains and so on and so the
issue is you know you got a resolve the
point because it's the foundation of
geometry which is the foundation of
mathematical physics both general
relativity and quantum mechanics
primarily those two and strength theory
of weighing far behind right and so we
need to figure out you know what we mean
by this important word I mean this is an
important word in mathematical physics
the point okay now what is geometry and
that's also puts it in perspective here
you have a couple of statements all
these that I'm gonna mention are going
to be from official sources okay these
are from universities from think tanks
these are all official sources that I'm
gonna be putting up here I put their
name because I don't want to embarrass
them but if anyone asked me for the
references I've got it today geometry is
the study of shape and size geometry was
probably first debunked to measure the
earth and its objects another fellow
says or another site says geometry the
branch of mathematics with primary
subject is spatial relationships and
shapes of bodies
and geometry studies spatial
relationships and shapes while ignoring
other properties of real bodies density
weight color etc okay okay so would we
put the point in in all that in that
context well here here you have
statements and say we may think of a
point as a dot on a piece of paper a
point has no length or width okay and
another phone another site so they quit
has no size points are infinitely small
like the fact that no size and small you
know kind of they don't go together you
know either it has size and it's small
or it doesn't have size and you can see
the how all these mathematicians don't
care about qualitative asks we just blab
nonsense contradictions they don't even
realize what they're saying but you know
they always put a little dot that looks
somewhat like that and that one to me I
don't know maybe my I said it's failing
me I don't know but it looks like it's
got width and height you tell me if you
think it's that true okay okay but yeah
we do have a problem because these
people are saying that this thing is
small but it has no size kind of man
can't reconcile those two statements to
be honest with you but you know what I
see there seems to have size and is
small yeah sure but then you know what
are they saying okay so here we have we
look up you know to see if we can find
the definition of the point and I went
through YouTube and there's several
people who explain geometry and so they
go out there and they start with the
foundations they start with point line
and plane okay and so I said well let's
see what they have to say about the
point okay I think it's a fair thing
that's where you're gonna learn you know
say okay let's see what a point is and
this is one guy he starts out he says
points lines and planes undefined terms
and you see him pointing at the point
and he says well you know that dot and
the word point and all that stuff that
I'm pointing to
it's an undefined term okay I don't know
maybe this guy got his degree from
Harvard University and that's why he
knows nothing you know the these thirty
Greek colleges third level colleges you
know that they don't teach you anything
and it's just for getting jobs and so
this guy must have studied over there I
don't know Harvard or Cambridge you know
one of those let's see maybe someone
else knows or has a better idea
and here's another one and you don't
know if these up yourself on the
internet you'll find them in YouTube so
section one dash one points lines and
planes undefined terms and then you have
point eight which the guy is scribbling
there on the board and he says it's in
an undefined term as well oh maybe this
guy study at the same school the other
guy studied I don't know so I went to
another site and here they don't even
define it they just go in and they give
examples okay these are the examples
they give they say all these are points
so I don't know what a point is but
these are examples of a point and I'm
sure if I look at the ice cream cone or
the tip of the pencil or whichever one
of those I want to find that it's got
width and height or you know some size
it's probably three dimensional and no
matter how far I go to the last atom I'm
gonna find a three dimensional atom so I
don't know what they mean by point are
they saying that the point is a tip of
something and that tip is one atom and
that atom is what three dimensional or
zero dimensional which is it yeah so so
yeah I've got a little bit of problem
with all these people are skirting the
definition saying one I'm gonna define
what a point is but I'm gonna use the
word I'm going to use the concept or the
object or whatever and then tell me it's
the same thing as the what is it a tip
of a pencil right and if I look at my
pencil you if I look at the tip I can
see it and so that tip must be made of
many atoms so that's gotta be at least
3d but okay take it to the limit
last atom the 30 tip well that I don't
has to be 3d and so how can they say it
has no size when the examples they give
are 3d
ok so we go to another one see if maybe
someone can resolve this issue and this
file says the same thing as the others
he says points lines planes undefined
terms and undefined term does not have a
formal definition but there's an
agreement about what they mean well how
can there be agreement if no one knows
what they're talking about
no one can define the term hugging there
and be agreed agreement on what what are
they agreeing to whether they sign the
contract too
so so we got a serious problem because
these people cannot define the word
point they're gonna use the word and
they say well you know what I mean
you know and no I don't I don't know
what you mean what do you mean by the
word point I mean it's gonna be the
foundation of geometry which is the
foundation of mathematical physics
space-time is described in terms of the
point quantum particles are described in
terms of the point and so if you're
gonna use that as foundation for
everything you better defined the point
because it's a very crucial very
strategic turn and you can't say well
it's an undefined term what do you mean
and as a minimum I would love to know I
would love to know if they're saying
it's an object or an abstract concept
it's either a physical object or an
abstract concept I mean I'd like to know
which of those two it is okay but when
they say what's the tip of a pen and
while they're talking about an object
that's tip of my pen is is an object and
they're gonna say well it's love or now
that's a concept so it's the point love
or is it the tip of my pencil we got a
problem here because we don't have even
these notions established for the word
point something as basic as that okay
and remember geometry is based on this
point this is what's gonna
all the geometries okay okay so we got
another site to see if maybe someone
clarify this all for us and this is what
these people say they say bath was about
making definitions
well okay love that if you're doing
geometry that no amount of physical
torture will get me to define a point a
contradiction
it's an undefined term inutes undefined
on purpose
oh okay deliberately okay
Hilbert Sachs if this is another these
are different sites
okay Hilbert's axioms are a set of 20
assumptions okay
the undefined primitives are point line
playing against a none defined the word
point is often left undefined often I
thought it was always not often in
geometry text it is pretty easy for us
to conceptualize a point okay but it is
quite difficult to define exactly why
would a point be so difficult to define
what's the issue okay so you look up why
it's difficult to define and that's what
they come up with they say points lines
and planes are the foundations of the
whole system of geometry okay but point
line and plane aren't all undefined
terms whoa how can that be
yeah how can it be well any definition
we could give them would depend on the
definition of some other mathematical
idea that these three terms help define
in other words the definition would be
circular and another side says the words
point lines and planes are left
undefined again everybody agrees on
that's right
or rather defined by usage in most
geometries in other words what it's
called a functional definition they
define it at the end first they use it
then you say well if if I forget that
you find it don't worry about it okay
we does avoid circularity again talking
about circularity if we define a term
okay we're definition circle back to one
previously defined this tradition was
only started about a hundred years ago
by David Hilbert however we can form
definitions using our
define terms aha well I mean I think you
could say that about any word in the
dictionary that no matter what word you
try to define you're gonna use other
words and those require other words and
those other words and so it's all
circular and we might as well have to
find anything that's what these people
are saying for the word point so what do
we stand
well apparently after all that rigmarole
you know we don't know what a point is
they can't define it they're going to
use it they put a dot on the board as
you can see in some of those so-called
definitions or non definitions they put
a dot and they say that's a point okay
that's a point what is that look like a
smudge on the board maybe a ink blot
them on the paper or what is that I've
seen a we'll call it a blob is that a
good word okay well quite a blob from
now on not a point quite a blob or I
don't know a smudge and again the
question is that uh whether it's an
object or a concept and these people try
to clarify that that point okay if you
think about the structure of math as a
tree there has to be something at the
bottom of the tree okay some objects
that aren't defined why objects that
aren't define and you use those to
define something else I have no idea
what this guy is talking about a point
is one of these objects okay so it's an
object finally we get a statement that a
point is an object yeah it is undefined
an undefined object that's like saying a
table is undefined in science we don't
define objects maybe that's why these
people are having trouble okay you get
to that in a minute
it's just an object again stating it's
an object in geometry people usually
think of points lines and planes as
undefined objects love the word object
okay and another side says many physical
objects suggest the idea of a point
examples include the corner of a block
the tip of a pencil a thought on the
sheet of
okay such things are called models or
representations or pictures of points
okay pictures of points like saying well
I got a picture of an elephant and then
pictures a picture although they show
only approximately the idea in mind I
don't know what these people are talking
about I mean you know I show a tree I
bring a tree and I'm saying well this is
a picture of a tree you say okay and I
say but don't take it seriously I mean
this is not really a tree what do you
mean by that I mean let's go outside of
my yard now point to a tree and said
well this is a tree well that's no
longer a picture of a tree it's the real
McCoy it's the real thing
and they say yeah but that's that's not
the tree the picture you had problems
with now I'm showing you the real thing
you're saying that's a tree but it's not
a tree it sounds like the people who do
extinction you know we're animals but
we're not animals yeah they love that
and these dualities you know it comes in
handy for any discussion you can always
get away from being punished right okay
so one way to get to the bottom of this
maybe I don't know because like you saw
in my the advertisement for this video I
said that the ancients had no idea what
a point was either I mean Plato
Aristotle Socrates all these you claim
you know they have no idea what a point
was either they weren't able to define
it but you couldn't try to synthesize
the knowledge of the age of the ancient
Greeks and you put it in a book called
elements okay about 300 BC about a
hundred years after Alexander founded
Alexandria in northern Egypt
well this Greek guy was living there in
Alexandria and he wrote his book over
there and this is what you could tells
us about especially about the point he
taught me you wrote 13 books on geometry
and in his first book he defines what a
point is and this is what mister Euclid
has to say about he says a point first
first line first definition okay point
is that which has no part that's the
translation we have today he's saying
it's got no size no length width or
height no that mentions no no volume
that's what he's saying yeah that's
that's what we get from this you know
maybe there's another interpretation but
that's the interpretation that was given
over the ages you know that what this
guy was saying is that you know a point
is nothing yeah nothing that's equal to
the zip and but then he says the ends of
line of a line are points so we have two
ends of a line they're points okay I
don't know what a line is yet we're not
gonna get to that until later but I mean
right now he says the end of line are
points so if a line is a physical object
you saying that a point is a physical
object but this physical object or this
object has no shape no size no volume no
dimensions is that what they're saying
here and then got another definition
number 16 and the point is called the
center of the circle
well center is a concept Center is not a
physical object I don't know of any
object called Center yeah but if you
know when bringing it to the conference
put it on the table so we know what a
center looks like hey all alone I don't
want any other edge of the center yeah
senators concept and so how can the
center be a point and also the end of
line or the line which apparently refers
to some kind of object a line right
since the end of these are points so
we're thinking about something visible
but at least two dimensions and then he
says it's the same thing you know the
point is a center which is a concept so
he got a problem we already have wrong
with Euclid because he's got a
contradiction between his example he
says in one case
they formed the end of a line the other
that formed a center of something which
is an a constant abstract concept so
here are a serious problem the word
point because it forms the foundations
of physics under one hand forms the
foundations of mathematical physics
really not physics
I caught mathematics and it forms the
foundation of geometry which is the
foundation of mathematical physics and
they haven't been able to define it in
2,000 years or more talking about maybe
twenty three hundred years at least they
have been able to define it okay they
don't know what it is and it turns out
that you stare at it and here I'll see
you show you can you see that someone
draws that out of the red thing okay
just the red one there in the center can
you see it if you can see it well that
looks like it has shape size as a
minimum it's got dimensions hided with
even think that it's an object that
represents what we would call objects
things that have shape size unit cetera
and how can that not be defined if you
know either it's a concept then we
define it or we point to it and it's an
object and here I can point to it and so
obviously I can point to that thing
because you can see it it's an object
among others the reason right and so we
got a problem because this thing is
gonna form the foundations of this
discipline we call it geometry and it
turns out no one can define it but what
you're staring at his obvious it's like
he's staring at a dog and you say that's
a dog and then someone said and then the
guy tells you said well I can't define
it well yeah we don't define objects
such as dogs and trees and rocks we
point to them and we can point to this
guy but if we point to it then it's a
dot that's what is in front of our eyes
that is patently what is in front of
your eyes an object
some kind it could be 3d it could be 2d
no problem but it's got shape it's got
size okay we point then and call it a
point then that's an object so what's
the problem
why are they trying to define it after
2,000 years you would think that they
would have figured out that you can't
define an object that's the issue and
these people haven't figured that out in
2,000 years and that is astonishing for
me it's astonishing that they have not
figured out that you don't define
objects you point to them and name them
and if it's a concept then you have to
define it and so maybe that's why you
have trouble defining it because they
have trouble defining the concept and
what is the concept it's a mixture
between the object dot and what they
purport to represent with this thought
which is location so if you take
location and you try to put it with a
tree they don't match locations of con
some tree is an object and yeah you
can't you can't blend them you can't mix
them you can't you yeah there are
unrelated totally okay and you're not
drawing some pictures of of this some of
you have seen this in the past probably
love.we rubriz up with the heart good
right will you represent with an angel
location we represent with a dot the so
called point and I guess if you have
half a point
that's half a location I mean is that
what these people are saying that you
can represent half a location are we
talking about things are we talking
about concepts here ok so let's look at
the summary of what I'm trying to say
here ok so that we keep this in mind I'm
gonna continue with geometry these next
few sessions and here here it is the
reasoning ok geometry is the study of
shapes and sizes that's what they say
that geometry is geometry is the
foundation
mathematical physics right everyone
claims that the point is the building
block of geometry but everyone casually
confesses that they can't define the
strategic word point everyone
illustrates a smudge that has width and
height and object something that has
shape okay
despite staring you directly at what's
in front of you okay at the 2d dot the
theorist tells you that the point that
is in front of your eyes has no size no
volume no dimensions no shake let me
look again I see a purple thing that has
size volume while you maybe you know
area at least right dimensions and shape
and and so how come the theories to
telling me that what my eyes are seeing
are now what they're seeing I'm seeing
black and he's saying no you're seeing
white huh what do you mean I'm I'm
seeing black no no you're seeing white
so you know the way I like to look at
this is that what these people doing is
this you know they're selling you a
whopper now son you some snake oil here
some nasty kool-aid you know and so the
question is whether you're gonna buy
this kool-aid because remember that's
the starting point they're going to
build a whole structure on top of this
so-called point okay so I think the
criteria the criticism is on the money
we have a problem a serious problem
because we have geometry it's founded on
the point the point is undefined they
can't tell you what's an object or a
concept some people say it's an object
some people later say well that's a
location and of course if they can't
merge the location where the object with
a tree with a dog with a rock then we
have a serious problem we have you know
a clash because they're trying to
reconcile a physical thing with an
abstraction with a concept and no wonder
they have trouble or an impossibility
and defining it I'll never be able to
define it and they can't just say well
if we happen to define it with this
definition would be circular because we
need other words now that applies to any
word in the dictionary you need other
words that they find the first word so
we're done with that we need definitions
in physics speaking in science because
we need to talk rationally so we need to
know understand what the dissertation is
about and what the theorist is trying to
tell you the only way we're going to
understand it if he defines the crucial
terms efficient the ones that make or
break his theory in this case point is a
crucial term because he's gonna talk
everything about points he's gonna say
that planes are points lines are points
solids are points you can say everything
is pointy before dimensional space-time
is Earth is made of points he's going to
say the particles are made of points at
quantum mechanics Chara point they talk
about point charges and point masses so
clearly if if the word point is superb
they're going to use it every two
seconds in all these disciplines or sub
disciplines well all I can say is you
have to define it you can't say well the
foundation we don't know what that is
but let's continue and try to understand
what I'm talking about no you can't do
it you got if you find a point or you
got to establish at least if it's an
object or a concept if it's an object if
it's a dot we're done use the dot and if
they say well we can't use the dot the
real dot the two-dimensional dot that's
not what's important in mathematics but
in here that's what I have in front of
me that's what a dot latter point is
that's what you pointed to when you said
point and if and if the dot is not the
point
if that thing I'm staring at that
two-dimensional circle or square or
whatever you put there and smudge is not
the point then what is the point and
they say well it's a location
and if it's a location why did you use
the word location why did you have to
use the word point and confuse me by
saying stare at that dot and assume that
it's got note that mentions no size no
volume but it does the one that's in
front of me does
yeah but make believe make believe it's
not there so this is the problem the
problem is we don't have a definition
for point naught because the definition
would be circular but because they're
trying to unite or merge or blend an
object Iraq with a concept love and yeah
you can't merge those two things because
they're incompatible conceptually
incompatible and so that's what they're
trying to do with the point they're
trying to merge the dot with a location
and when they need the dot they draw it
on the board they say see that's point a
and you say okay I understood then they
said but it's got no size yeah but it
does have size yeah but see the size is
not important in math what's important
is the location that it represents well
why don't you call it location right you
fool me why'd you sell me this kool-aid
the snake-oil saying that dot is the
point I mean if the dot is the point
let's do it we use the dot because
that's what's in front of me
objectively and if the dot is not the
point
if point is really a location use the
word location we don't need the word
point the only purpose of the word point
is to try to blend to Eric and syllable
notions an object with a concept claim
to the crowd it's undefined we can't
define it we don't know why problem in
the years it and we're gonna draw a
point and use the location whenever we
need it that's why that's the status of
the point today and after all this said
and done after I said all that we don't
use points in physics or in science we
have no use for the word point okay
sorry that destroys your religion if it
but I'm gonna continue with that show
that we do have no use whatsoever for
the word point we have no use for sling
there really none of the concepts that
came out of geometry and abstract
science we can call it science geometry
has to do with measurement and
measurement has nothing at all to do
with science for with physics okay with
that I hope I gained enough rotten eggs
and tomatoes on my face and I'll see you
I'll see you on Wednesday
we'll see you that bye bye